hello again let's get you more on that
breaking news sky news understands a
drought is expected to be declared
tomorrow in the south west the person to
bring us all this breaking news today is
tamara
hi again tomorrow tell us more
hi nick yes across the southwest of
england a drought will be declared
tomorrow sky news understands so there
you will expect if we live in the south
west to have a series of restrictions on
domestic and commercial use of water now
this may not come as a huge surprise
after the record high temperatures we've
seen and the really incredibly parched
conditions we've seen across a lot of
the country but the south west of
england has been one of the hardest hit
regions and we expect that announcement
to come tomorrow how this works is the
environment agencies drought group get
together and look at lots of statistics
about levels of rainfall how much water
is left in rivers and reservoirs and
lakes and what the temperatures are
forecast to be over the coming weeks to
decide whether drought conditions have
been reached there aren't any particular
targets in all those categories they
just decide whether all those things
come together coming together
constitutes a drought and they can give
an indication of how severe and
long-lasting that drought may be now
when that happens and it's happened
before we had a drought declared in 2018
and a more severe one back in 2011 but
when that happens the water companies in
that area the main one being southwest
water will then announce restrictions
and the environment agency will check
they are sticking to them so we would
expect hosepipe vans across the
southwest from tomorrow and also
businesses whether it's car washes or
farming businesses may face restrictions
on the amount of water they can use so
after a really tough time for farmers
they may now not be able to irrigate at
their crops commercially from tomorrow
but will have all those restrictions
announced in full so drought conditions
in the southwest of england and it's not
inconceivable that drought conditions
could follow in other parts of the
country too with the thames water
company already indicating that it's
looking at a hosepipe ban in the coming
weeks yeah we've got southeast ward and
we tomorrow bringing in hosepipe band 2
tomorrow thank you for now